What is it about war movies
that drive you the most crazy?
The fact that almost everything in
them is an accurate, almost everything.
Biggest thing that drives me fucking
crazy is when grenades create a fireball.
Really? Well, yeah. Cause it
happens in like every movie.
They throw a grenade and a 55 gallon
drum of gasoline explodes and people go
flying backwards and cars flip over.
If you throw a grenade,
it goes pop and it puts some dust up in
the air and if you're waiting for the
fireball, you're going to be there
for the rest of your natural life.
It's just not going and they're
not that effective. They're fun.
Don't get me wrong, but they're not
that effective. I did not know that.
They don't like create a
fireball. No, I've never seen
a grenade go off. Obviously.
I'm sure Jamie can pull one up. It
just goes poof. It's dust is all it is.
Seen one in a video.
I'm sure for a moment,
like the momentary explosion there
is a flash, but other than that,
it's literally just dust
flying up in the air. What?
What is the best military movie
that's the most accurate or the most,
the Least Offensive Navy seals starring
Charlie Sheen. Really? No, not at all.
Oh Jesus Christ. I'm wondering, fell down
that fucking guy.
Probably food more people in to come
into the seal teams than anybody else.
Oh my God. Really? Yeah.
I mean these fallen through skylights
with MP fives and handlebar mustaches.
You know, there's snipers calling
himself. God, I can't see anything.
I'm switching to starlight blasting
people through a concrete wall.
They're doing free fall
jumps are in submarines.
That's an entire 30 year career to
do all that shit and 60 minutes.
You take that expectation,
you come to the team just like God,
I'm kind of bored right now.
So was that the war areas saying Bang,
Bang, I'm going to run boys.
Yep. I want to make it.
And he's got the, the, the, the requisite.
A scarf around the neck and first off,
one of those.
So what kind of asshole wears a red
scarf and an environment where there's no
red. He's got green utilities on
from Vietnam. When I read, uh,
going to Shamal. Yeah. This
is so hilarious. So another
one, especially you would,
you know Charlie now,
like such a fucking psychotic
partier and so apparently apparently,
so they came to the buds compound and did
a little bit of training with the guys
and I guess there was some bathroom
breaks and they'd just be like, all right,
you guys ready for some more
PT? Oh really? That makes sense.
I've always see hearing that 18th hand,
but I want to believe it's true. Well,
you know who I hear trains
diligently and really hard, uh,
and like takes it super seriously and
he's like one of the most humble guys
you'll ever meet. He's Keanu Reeves.
That doesn't surprise me. Yeah.
It doesn't surprise me either, but
I heard some people that have, uh,
had interacted with him when
he was training for, um,
John Wick. Yeah. Including,
uh, my Jujitsu instructor, John
Jacques Machado, my friend.
He can Machado's John John's
brother and a bunch of other you.
He worked out with a bunch
of their Machado's. In fact,
I think Carlos as well. Uh,
but you know, he really wanted to
learn actual Jujitsu. So he ran,
she trained with them. Yeah. He did real
tactical courses and, and so his, uh,
his tactical proficiency
shows in that movie.
And so to get back to
stuff that bothers me,
it's the 72 round pistol magazine
cause I'm counting, I'm
like, Oh, 25 30, uh,
or the shotgun that has 48 rounds
in it so that I can't do it.
I'm like throwing stuff at the TV and
my wife just point, she says, get out.
Like
so Sicario I love Sicario.
There's a scene at the border that
has one of the most blatant, uh,
just errors in the movie.
There's a guy pointing a gun,
he's supposedly a CIA age
and he's pointing the gun
out the windshield and you
can see that the bolt to the rifle
is locked to the rear. Oh No.
Which means the armor onset handed it
to him and you know, clear and safe.
And he just went and they filmed it and
nobody caught it. And I saw that movie.
I'm like, turn that shit off. I
can't watch any. Of course. Yeah.
It ruins it for me now.
Why don't they fix stuff like that?
You would think that you're making a
movie about military or about guns?
Like yeah,
gun nuts are going to notice that they,
but they probably didn't catch it
in the editing pro. It's so fast.
It's probably up there for three
seconds. But if you know, I mean I,
you look at a gun and like you just,
if it was your primary tool for years,
you're going to, you're
looking for certain things
all the time. Yep. Here we go.
Look for someone who doesn't know though.
It looks super serious.
Well that's why they're still
watching the movie and I left. Yup.
Bolt to the rear.
Ah
Yeah. To the rear. Yup. Go
ahead and pull the trigger
there. Go ahead son. That shit.
Ah, obviously an empty
magazine. Yeah. Hey silly. Yeah,
so nobody caught that in the editing
process is what it is. Not See that? No.
Don't you think they digitally
could've moved that forward?
They 100% couldn't move cause he
didn't fire in that scene anyway. Yeah.
Just pushed up, pitch up,
just Photoshop that sucker.
I mean it makes sense in a
way less significant thing.
I get crazy when I watch people play pool
and movies that obviously can't play.
Oh, I could drive me nuts. Drives me nuts.
Like if I see someone like it's supposed
to be some pool hustler and I see,
so they have a bullshit
bridge and they're,
they're gripping the like you can
see things in movies like, uh,
my friends who smoked cigarettes say
they can tell when someone doesn't smoke.
Oh for sure. Yeah, because when you
smoke, there's just so like a casual,
real relaxed way that you're holding the
cigarette and the way you're drawing up.
But when someone's like never
smoked before and like, yeah,
they've got this weird thing to do and
like, oh that guy doesn't really smoke.
I'm like, how the fuck can you tell
it? Because I smoke. It's like,
another thing that bugs me is you watch
any tactical scene where they're like
moving down a hallway and it's like,
why is your gun pointed at your
buddies face? Like, that's not cool.
Why are you aiming as like, and then
the way that they make entry into rooms,
it's like, awesome. I like to play
Russian roulette with my life as well.
Like drives me. Absolutely.
What about zero dark 30?
That movie fucking sucks.
What sucks about it? You know what
drove me crazy that, that last time?
Do we have the redhead lady? What is
yelling at all those trained killers?
I was like,
I don't think they listen to her.
There are some creative liberties that
are taken in that movie from soup to
nuts. I mean, like was that person,
the lady who yelled at those guys are
the ones, the woman who was in charge of,
was that a real human in real life?
It was based off of a real human for sure.
Like a lot of the things in that movie
were based on real events. However,
if you're trying to get tickets to get
people seats or their butts and seats,
you get a glamorized stuff. So a lot of
people, because in that movie, you know,
the, um, the source drives up in
the vehicle and detonates himself.
That actually happened that killed
a bunch of people in calced. Um,
if as long as you look at it as
entertainment, that movies. Okay.
If you look at it with a refined, I
like are they doing this correctly? No.
They're all going to die.
Yeah. I mean it's, uh, it just,
I, we would need another four hours to
literally go down the list of things,
but it's just things are compressed.
Things that would never happen,
happen for the sake of creating a, an,
an, an, an an intoxicating or did, uh,
uh, emotional scene on camera and it's
tough to watch cause I'm sitting there,
I'm like, get out of the door, get
out of the door, get out the door.
I'm getting anxiety watching these damn
movies because you don't hang out in
front of open doors unless
you want to get shot.
Now how many different things were
fucked up about that movie? Uh, Joe,
only the things that we're
after the opening scene.
That's a long movies. A disaster. Yeah.
It's just, I don't want to talk about it.
Dumb ass like myself. I'm like,
that's a good fucking movie scene.
It's pretty realistic. Well,
think about it from entertainment.
It's a great entertaining movie.
It asks the same question about the
movie American sniper or lone survivor.
They're all based around certain things
that have been enhanced to make it more
entertaining. Yes. And B, and I get
it. They're there to make money.
They're not there to tell historically
accurate. Do you know Marcus?
I do not know Marcus well, but
I do know Marcus. I know him.
I don't know how he felt.
I don't know if you'd ever say he was
a whole felt making a movie. Yeah.
But I mean, I'm sure they only listened
to him so much, you know? Yeah.
Uh, given how I can, again,
having not been there and I can only
imagine how horrific that incident must be
for him to deal with on a daily level.
I would bet he wasn't very involved.
I would almost rather them if that was me,
I think I would almost rather say,
you know what,
just make the movie that you want to
make because I don't want to sit here and
explain exactly what happened and recreate
these scenes and talk about how this
person died over here. Like I would
just go, you know, go to town.
Is there any movie that you've
ever seen about war where you go,
that makes sense. First 10 minutes of
Saving Private Ryan is unbelievable.
Oh yeah.
Not for accuracy.
For capturing the essence of what it
feels like and the switch between utter
fear to excitement, to joy, to
anger in the matter of a second,
another movie that does a good
aspect or a good job of capturing,
capturing some of those aspects I
would say is also Black Hawk down,
not for accuracy,
but to capture the chaos that have,
how a plan can come unraveled and how
just how chaotic it can be enhanced.
How sometimes you can feel so helpless
but you're only solution is to drive in
to the problem instead of
moving away from it. So those,
those capture the essence of it?
Well, from a technical perspective,
I honestly can not think of a
single movie that does a justice.
Wow. It would have to be like a 50
hour movie though because of course,
I mean Black Hawk down I think was a
multiple day incident in that movie's 90
minutes. Right. So they get
rid of all the boring bs stuff.
That is actually what you do.
The vast majority of your job.
If I look at my career,
probably greater than 95% of my career
I spent training and then 5% is spent in
combat. Really? Yep. And
that is, that is average.
I would say there are people who are
maybe a little bit higher and people who
are a little bit lower,
but you're not going to spend more than
at most maybe 10% of your career in
combat. Even if your job is directly
tied to combat cause you gotta train,
you get a plan. The missions, I mean our,
our normal planning cycle was 24 to 72
hours sitting in front of PowerPoint.
Considering whether or not I should hang
myself or blow my brains out because
we're arguing over the font that we're
using to submit permission approval.
Really? Oh, you're studying the,
whether you're studying the terrain.
I've had slides and
mission briefs sent back,
not be approved because I
didn't orient the helicopter,
the correct direction on the
slide. They're like, hey,
you need to fix this and then resubmit it.
Like if you want it to shut down
the average day of military,
it wouldn't be through a kinetic act.
You would need to put some type of code
into Microsoft office and we're done
because we operate on
Microsoft PowerPoint, Microsoft
Word and Microsoft office.
We'd sit there and we'd plan and we
would brief and we'd submit for approval.
That's three days. Then you'd go do an
objective that would last for 10 hours.
Repeat, repeat the cycle on.
To add for that, it's, well,
you break up the tasks so each like is
it the last thing you would want is one
person creating the entire plan.
So somebody is doing the communication
plan in the medivac plan,
the insertion plan,
the route planning you.
We don't ever really brief what we're
going to do inside of the objective,
because that's kind of the soup and
nuts that you train for at all times.
Like that's everything is to get there
and then, okay, that's actually our job,
but we focus on all those other
things. Then primary, secondary,
tertiary plan for each
one of those things,
phase lines for each one of those things.
None of that has ever
shown up in any movie. Uh,
what show up in any movies
is vast majority of time
the intelligence is bad and
you hit what's called a dry hole.
You go to a building,
you approached the structure, you
breached the door, and it's just,
the intelligence is wrong. It's
either empty or it's the wrong person.
That happens all the time. That
doesn't, it's not exciting though.
So we pay the people money,
they fixed their door and we go back
and we try to find the person again.
None of that shows up in any of
the mediums because it's too,
they're too compressed.